[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24
más romero sala ya está conmigo en el
estudio de la mañana de martes mar para
seguir hablando por supuesto de esta
viruela del mono ahora para explicar
todas sus dudas que todavía pesan sobre
este brote de la viruela del mono que
además la organización mundial de la
salud ya la declaró digamos una
enfermedad pues para tener que vernos a
para tener que estar está
mal por supuesto como siempre por el
apunte y pues precisamente porque ahora
es una enfermedad de emergencia pública
internacional aquí vamos a estar
ofreciendo contexto del este virus del
brote para entenderlo mejor sabemos que
nos tiene que preocupar y que no sabemos
muchas cosas de esta enfermedad sobre
todo porque está relacionada con la
viruela humana y esa enfermedad ya sea
erradicó y eso nos ha dejado mucha
información sobre cómo combatirla pero
también tenemos muchas dudas muchos
interrogantes que no se están
respondiendo todavía para empezar no
sabemos de qué animales proviene sabemos
que es una enfermedad de origen animal
zoonótica pero no sabemos cuál es el
reservorios o si el grupo de animales
que del cual salta el es bruce a los
humanos no es los monos como su nombre
pareciera indicar se cree que son unos
roedores tampoco tenemos buena
explicación sobre si hay unas mutaciones
o como un afectado estas mutaciones del
virus que ahora hagan que este bit que
este brote se esté comportando de una
forma diferente a lo que habitualmente
estábamos acostumbrados tampoco tenemos
total claridad sobre su transmisión
sabemos que requiere un contacto
estrecho que a través por ejemplo de las
heridas que provoca se puede contagiar
pero también se está debatiendo sobre si
se puede transmitir a través del aire y
algunos estudios recientes han
encontrado rastros distribuidos también
en el líquido seminal también entonces
eso podría dar pistas sobre otros otras
vías de transmisión y porque hay todos
estos interrogantes pues porque esta
enfermedad se dejó de estudiar sobre
todo toda esta familia de virus los [__]
pocos virus se llaman que son también
los de la viruela humana y el de la
viruela del mono se dejaron de estudiar
por ejemplo cuando se erradicó la
viruela a pesar de que haya habido
brotes de viruela del mono más pequeños
y bueno de hecho lo denunciaban un poco
en una editorial publicada este fin de
semana en la revista neicer que las
investigaciones dependan también de la
capacidad y de los recursos de los
países para investigar escuchamos lo
la falta de investigación sobre la
viruela del mono a pesar de centenares
de casos y docenas de muertes cada año
ha dejado el mundo deplorablemente poco
preparado para este brote global cada
infección zoonótica debería ser causa de
preocupación pero la financiación de la
investigación sólo parece llegar cuando
afecta duramente países de ingresos
altos
bueno mar hay mar hay dos cosas también
muy buenas de esto esta vida del mono es
menos nociva digamos que la vida normal
y hay una vacuna contra estadios la del
mono que se puede utilizar pero que
sabemos de esta vacuna en la seguridad
de la eficacia si vamos a repasar los
datos vamos a explicarlo bien porque
además y hay países que están empezando
a vacunar a los grupos que se consideran
de riesgo de hecho es una vacuna
originalmente desarrollada contra la
vacuna contra la viruela humana perdón
que se está usando ahora contra la
viruela del mono es de tercera
generación de las más nuevas que existen
al contra la viruela la desarrolló una
farmacéutica danesa que se llamaba
variante nórdica y se comercializa bajo
el nombre de guineos en eeuu e inba mex
en europa por eso hay veces que hay como
una confusión sobre si son dos vacunas
distintas es la misma es una vacuna de
virus vivo sin embargo que no tiene
capacidad de replicarse y por eso es una
de las vacunas más seguras que existen
contra la viruela las de primera y
segunda generación de hecho son vacunas
bastante salvajes en la grama en
bastante y de hecho dejan una marca
grande en el brazo muy característica
también de estas campañas de vacunación
a se cree que es efectiva en un 85%
contra la viruela del mono pero la
verdad es importante que tomemos esa
cifra con algo de precaución porque no
se sabe del cierto esta cifra del 85%
viene de un estudio que se publicó en
1986 después de seis años estudiando
unas 2000 personas más o menos que
habían estado expuestas en república
democrática del congo al virus de la
viruela del mono y una de sus
conclusiones como vemos aquí es que la
propagación es ineficiente de persona a
persona incluso en casos de exposición
máxima que el virus está mal adaptado
para una transmisión sostenible
sostenida perdón y que no conlleva
problemas de salud significativo es
claramente dadas estas conclusiones
deberíamos reevaluar un poco este
estudio deberíamos reevaluar estas
afirmaciones porque esas cifras y esto
al menos estas conclusiones que saca el
estudio no están en sintonía con lo que
está pasando actualmente entonces
esperamos tener un poquito más de luz
sobre la eficacia de la vacuna también
en un tiempo cuando hayamos visto pues
qué sucede con estas personas que se
están vacunando actualmente así es más
dejamos entonces a un lado la viruela
del mono para pasar lamentablemente a
otro brote de hepatitis aguda en los
niños que también por supuesto hemos
hablado aquí en nuestro espacio de salud
si vamos de susto en susto de miedos en
miedos pero bueno aquí vamos explicando
pues todos estos brotes para saber un
poquito más cada vez y estar un poquito
también más tranquilos porque porque
ahora son los estudios nuevos que
arrojan algo más de claridad sobre un
origen potencial importante esta palabra
todavía potencial son dos estudios de la
universidad de glasgow y de londres que
se publicaron independientemente pero
que llegan a conclusiones muy similares
y es que hay un nuevo factor que ha
saltado a la vista en estos estudios un
virus adeno asociado 2 a a v2 un virus
adeno asociado quiere decir que necesita
de otro tipo de virus normalmente
adenovirus pero pueden ser otros para
replicarse que sin eso no se puede
replicar es un virus común de hecho que
probó resfriados o enfermedades
gastrointestinales en los niños y
básicamente lo que vieron es que estaba
presente en los niños afectados por
estos casos de hepatitis aguda de origen
desconocido estaban en todas las
muestras de sangre y en todas las
muestras de hígado que tomaron estaba
presente este v 2 en cambio en los niños
sanos en los niños con infecciones de
otros virus que podrían estar
relacionados pero que no tenían
hepatitis buenos niños con hepatitis
pero que no eran de este caso generan
otros tipos de inflamación del hígado no
encontrarán ninguna muestra de este v2
por lo tanto pues parece que tendría
algo de relación con estos estos casos
de cuyo origen se desconocía además
parece que en los niños con esta
enfermedad que desarrollaron la
enfermedad más grave de hepatitis habría
un factor genético relacionado con la
respuesta inmune que podría hacer
agravar estos casos por lo tanto estamos
hablando de tres factores este virus
adeno asociado un adenovirus u otro
virus que provoque la infección y este
factor genético cuando coinciden estas
tres cosas podrían darse estos casos de
hepatitis digamos baratos de la pandemia
19 no tendrían hay que ver con este
virus de hepatitis pues digamos que si
no porque definitivamente el timing
digamos el momento en el que todo
parecía sospechoso y por eso muchos los
llevó a pensar que el sars cop 2 tendría
algo que ver pero este estudio estos dos
estudios de hecho alejan un poco esta
teoría porque pues por qué revisaron la
cantidad de anticuerpos a cuántos niños
tenían anticuerpos contra el commit 19 y
se correspondía con la población general
es decir que no parecía que hubiera
niños que habían tenido más que en otros
casos de infecciones por kobe 19
entonces bueno sin embargo una de las
hipótesis que manejan eso sí es que pues
por los confinamientos los niños no
estuvieran expuestos más comúnmente a
este tipo de virus y por eso ahora se
hayan agrupado digamos y lo hayamos
visto como un factor común mientras que
antes podían surgir de forma esporádica
que eran dudas por resolver sobre todo
pues sería importante tener una muestra
más grande de estos estudios como
veíamos eran muy pequeñas pero pues sin
embargo algo de luz empieza a aparecer
sobre posibles causas de esta hepatitis
marc como siempre gracias por toda la
información de salud de nuevas mañana
miércoles con más salud aquí en directo
américa y vamos a hablar con un marc esa
debe